it's great to welcome to the program
today Jared Tate who is the founder of
digibytes digibytes I oh where you can
learn more jared great to talk to you
yeah great to be on thanks for having me
on so this is an interesting time in the
world of crypto and more generally in
the global economy and there's a lot of
things sort of overlapping and
interacting that I think are going to be
making for an interesting several years
first of all the the new book blockchain
2035 the digital DNA of internet 3.0
talk a little bit about the overlap
between crypto and the sort of next wave
of the Internet as it is now being
described what is the sort of role that
you see that crypto will have in that
space yeah absolutely you know as you
said it is a very interesting time to be
alive there's a lot happening not only
in technology and innovation but as you
said also geopolitically and around the
world and I believe blockchain
technology is going to have a very
pivotal role in this new wave and a
little bit of background about myself I
have been involved with Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies full-time since 2012
and over time I keep getting a lot of
the same questions asked and I decided
about 16 18 months ago to write a book
so though the book blockchain 2035 the
digital DNA of Internet 3.0 is an
accumulation of all the experience
insights and conversations that I've had
with businesses political leaders and
other people over the past you know six
seven years and just a little bit of
background about didja by digibind
itself was launched as a blockchain in
2014 in January 10th and the headline
that was used to create the Genesis
block was USA Today target 110 million
customers data stolen and you know a lot
of people ask like okay well blockchain
just showed up out of nowhere well the
reality is it didn't just come out of
nowhere it's actually the advancement of
over 60 70 years of some of the most
brilliant
mathematical minds on the planet as well
as cryptographers as well as research
often funded in secret by the US
government right so this this technology
just didn't pop up out of nowhere and it
to me the most underestimated aspect of
this technology is cybersecurity and the
benefits that it offers and the impact
it's going to have on different
different industries from health care to
you know securing voting systems to
securing your healthcare records it
really comes down to giving you the
ability to control your own data and
information in this coming internet 3.0
because the internet we have today was
never designed to be secure you know
encryption and security was it was an
afterthought because you know back in
the arap in that days you know it was a
bunch of researchers that different
institutions that trusted each other
they would look up each other via IP
addresses and a phonebook so that's uh
you know that's that's kind of I guess a
gateway in if you will
yeah more and more the people I'm
talking to recently are starting to sort
of distinguish or draw a line between a
lot of the different ICO projects that
are around and the sort of role of
blockchain and cryptocurrency more
generally going forward and I'm curious
whether you agree with with what seems
to be the position I'm hearing more and
more from people I talk to you which is
that 95 percent of the specific projects
that are launching and have launched
over the last couple of years are
essentially going nowhere and are not
going to contribute significantly to the
future of blockchain on the Internet
but that there is some fraction 5% what
doesn't really matter what the number is
there is a piece of this that is
actually going to play a significant
role in facilitating transactions as a
store of value and in working in some of
the other ways you're talking about do
you agree with that split is it
absolutely
you know I myself was absolutely baffled
by the ICO craze and I have seen
probably since I've been involved in
this industry since 2012 I probably seen
98 to 99 percent of projects that have
started and there's been a wave a lot of
them have been scams there's a lot of
fraudulent people and and tech in this
space but is the technology solid
absolutely and will it pay play a
pivotal role yes and you know I I mean
he is kind to say 5% but I think there's
at least a one or two percent of these
projects that are gonna be long-term and
the thing is you know when people hear
the term blotching and technology it's
almost more of an ideology I mean I hate
to say it but you know this whole
blockchain group has almost become
somewhat of a religion you know the we
call big Bitcoin maximalist but the
important thing - the good analogy and
the intro to that I use to the book is
if you imagine all the DNA in your body
you have DNA in your hair if DNA in your
fingertips you have DNA DNA strands
throughout your entire body
well what if all that DNA was located in
just your fingertip and you were
chopping some vegetables or some lines
for some cocktails and you slipped and
cut it off well you'd have a problem
right you know you couldn't have kids
your body but slowly wither and die well
nature didn't design us like this but
that's how our entire Internet is
architected today we have all these
central points of failure where we store
mass amounts of information and data and
once those are breached you know it's
game over
and a lot of times you know like I said
before security is an afterthought so a
blockchain really is is it's a paradigm
shift in computer science and the
architecture of data systems and to
degree economic models as we know it so
you know the this there's a spectrum of
blockchain technology and you have the
very very truly decentralized projects
like Bitcoin and didja byte you know did
you buy it was not in ICO there was no
company there's no foundation I is the
founder have less than a fraction of a
percentage of what's out there which you
know I wish I would have mined and kept
more oh he hears but it's a truly
decentralized system and that's why we
have such a powerful grassroots movement
and then on the other spectrum you have
a hundred percent centralized and
controlled projects ie for instance
ripple however ripple has provided some
legitimate use cases and you know in the
banking industry to speed up the
efficiency of sending money a lot of
people don't know that there is a cost
to moving money especially around the
world so Jared can you talk a little bit
about if we want to think about the
political impact that blockchain
technology
technology could have there are people
who talk about using block chain to
secure voting systems there are people
who talk about using blockchain for
universal basic income type programs the
likes of which Andrew yang and some
other presidential candidates talk about
there are discussions of using
blockchain in some way to stabilize or
secure national currencies I mean that
there's these and many other ideas if
you had to say what do you think is the
biggest political potential that
blockchain has to make an impact what
would it be
well it's transparency so whether it's
transparency and voting systems
transparency and how a ubi system is
actually dispersed and who actually ends
up being the net benefit you know
beneficiary of that system I cross the
board it's it's a transparent immutable
ledger and it's perfect for something
like a voting system because you know
once you've established a non border and
creating an identity for somebody on a
blockchain which I also feel like
blockchain is gonna be the future of
identity management you know why when I
go to get a car or I go to renew my
driver's license or if I go to get a
mortgage on a house why do I have to
re-establish my identity multiple times
over and over again if you look at the
net cost to the US and world economy for
just simply Rivera fiying identity you
could actually see an X exponential
boost just in productivity just from
streamlining that process now once you
do that you know things like health care
records voting in I'm not trying to
propose like a national blockchain ID
I'm saying that there are different ways
to do this but it really does at the end
of the day come down to transparency so
now in terms of the geopolitical aspect
you know the basis of this what we're
seeing from Russia China you know to
give you an example of 2016 I was given
a presentation in Beijing and I was
slated between two Chinese PhD
researchers in computer science and they
had a slide up there and they showed
that the basically that because the UK
government had made blockchain a top
priority national security that the
China needed to do that and that China
needed to basically use blockchain
technology alongside their
belt one Road initiative to basically
start displacing the US dollar and you
see what's happening in Russia Russia's
already experimenting with watching and
based voting systems but there is talk
of a digital backed ruble you saw it
with Venezuela
although Venezuela the way they executed
it I did it very poorly yes but we are
in the era of nation state backed
cryptocurrencies and block chains but
it's like I tell everybody you know you
cannot have the security and the
decentralized transparency that comes
along with the original vision of
Satoshi and what a blockchain is meant
to be if it's not decentralized so if
you have a private permission chain it's
no different than a database yeah when
you talk about Russia using this of
course we know that Russia is not
exactly known for the most transparent
open fair or accurate election so then
the idea of ways you know I immediately
start thinking of well could blockchain
be actually used rather than for
transparency but for the opposite if
it's used in the wrong way by the wrong
people absolutely you know we go into
this into the book I mean botching could
be used as the ultimate weapon for you
know humanity's enslavement to get all
Orwellian there but it can because what
we're really talking about like I said
before is the evolution of 60 70 years
of the most advanced mathematics and
cryptography on the planet I mean a lot
of the different components that are in
what we call blockchain you know for
instance the whole idea of public
private key cryptography that came from
dr. Merkel in 1969 and is in his
Stanford PhD and it was immediately
classified now we're just you know it's
just now hitting the mainstream so
there's a lot of a lot of this
technology is very powerful especially
with encryption can you talk a little
bit about in the sort of last bit of
time we have left very specifically what
is it that didja byte is and does in the
space so we've pioneered several
innovations over the last five years so
at the end of the day we have aimed to
be the most decentralized network and
cryptocurrency we can be so didja by
uses five independent
instead of just one for greater
decentralization you can find more about
that at digit I do but one of the things
that we've done is actually pioneered a
difficulty stability system that is
actually still a major flaw in Bitcoin
and that systems actually been adopted
by everything from aetherium to Bitcoin
cash to Z cash and dozens of other block
chains and you know we and then that's
just one of the many things we pioneered
but let's explain that for people that's
actually interesting for people who
don't know so with Bitcoin one of the
elements that is sort of part and parcel
to the system is that over time the
difficulty for mining Bitcoin which is
essentially solving problems increases
that difficulty increases and this is
something that has been talked about as
both potentially a benefit but also one
of the big problems and obstacles for
Bitcoin in the future you say that digi
byte has has solved that issue can you
talk a little more specific
the problem with Bitcoin is that
adjustment only occurs every two weeks
or 2016 blocks and when that adjustment
is made it doesn't occur fast enough and
further enough so we actually found this
out the hard way with with bitcoins
ten-minute block times what did you buy
launched in 2014 we had a two minute
block time we're down to 15 seconds now
so digibytes actually 40 times faster
but we have a real time difficulty
adjustment we call digit shield and then
it got morphed in a multi shield well
what that means is you can literally
take all the Bitcoin mining power in the
world throw it a digit by and you only
get 20% of the blocks because it's only
one algo there's no other
cryptocurrencies in the world that could
handle that the other problem is for
instance the other day there was and
I've learned against this publicly many
times there was a flood in China that
wiped out like 40% almost 40% of the
Bitcoin hash rate and the problem is is
when that hash rate falls too much it
freezes so if you remember the infamous
dogecoin I helped fix them in 2014 when
their blockchain froze for two days and
that's because that adjustment you'd
have what we called multi cool attacks
they would come they'd attack the
network they'd get a bunch they'd speed
up the block times so there was blocks
every few seconds they would go
but on the market and then they would
move onto the chain so they recycling
script coins they would go from like
coin to dogecoin to did you buy him back
right well that's why when Bitcoin cash
fort and there was the big drama in the
industry you know I was publicly saying
what's everybody waiting for when at the
time Bitcoin cash had ten percent of the
net hash rate of Bitcoin right and I I
told everybody it cannot keep up enough
it cannot catch up enough and that's why
there were several weeks of instability
and hours I think at what point it was
almost a half a day between blocks and
then they actually came to us and they
used our code and they fix that problem
so that's one of the things that we've
done and you know I kind of want to get
to technical because I know it tends to
lose people you can find more about it
on the website but that is a serious
flaw that still needs to be fixed in
Bitcoin what's up and coming in the next
year for did you bite so we just
launched digi assets which we have a lot
of very exciting projects that are
underway and what digi assets really is
it's the ability to issue other not
other broad chains but other projects
you know so I I don't want to use the
term ICO because I don't wanna mislead
people about for instance I'm working on
a platform that will allow people to
take for instance like a birth
certificate or a legal contract and then
upload that and put that in the
blockchain to help verify it not it
right stuff like that so anything can be
kind of a digital asset of value
anything that you hold unique artwork
songs media files that sort of stuff as
well as we are working with a few
partners to actually do securities in in
the European Union and as well as the UK
and then eventually the plan is the
United States a lot going on with
digibytes we've been speaking with
digibytes founder Jared Tate and you can
find out more at did you bite dot IO and
using the link down in the video
description
Jared really appreciate your time and
we'll continue following the project
yeah thank you David
it's a pleasure